I've fallen a bit in love it's quite
tricky as he has a very large mustache
and quite a military posture he only
speaks German French and Italian and he
died in 1900 I'm not sure mom and dad
would be happy but Friedrich Nietzsche
is really obsessing me at the moment
now Nietzsche was a classical scholar a
brilliant student of Asian Greece and
Rome and when he was 28 he wrote this
book the birth of tragedy which appalled
his fellow academics by the wildness of
its psychology that has fascinated
nature's rulers ever since in this book
Nietzsche tells us that Greek culture
was defined by two gods
now there were loads of gods in ancient
Greece as you probably remember from
school but to Nietzsche there were only
really two that mattered Apollo and
Dionysus both sons of Zeus Apollo is the
god of reason and the rational he is in
a lovely Roman copy of an original Greek
statue and yes it looks like his [ __ ]
fell off Nietzsche coined a term the
Apollonian to capture the atmosphere and
spirit of Apollo it's all about reason
calm wisdom and logical thinking imagine
it like some ideal psychologically
mature confident grown-up but then
finita there's this other pod Dionysus
who's the exact opposite he is about
chaos emotion instinct and impulse the
Dionysian involves runaway passion sex
madness and chaos Dionysus is also the
god of wine Nietzsche argues that the
opposition between Dionysus and Apollo
runs right through Greek culture in fact
through all of us we're all a
tantalizing mix of Dionysus and Apollo
half logical reasoning human half
frenzied impulse love in dancing beasts
Nietzsche believed that at their finest
the Greeks gave room for the tussle
between Apollo and
Isis weirdly for a philosopher Nietzsche
believed that Greek culture started to
go wrong when the Greeks tried to forget
about Dionysus they became too
Apollonian because of philosophy in
general and Socrates in particular with
the arrival of Socrates on the scene
the Greeks fell in love with the idea of
being able to control everything through
their minds being totally wise and able
to understand everything they turned
against drinking wine and done reason
Nietzsche argued that this was deeply
dangerous and that real wisdom comes
from accepting the Dionysian side of us
I love this message and I love that
Nietzsche gave us these two words
Apollonian and Dionysian to name
something that's in all of us but we
never knew what to call there's a side
of us that wants to understand that
longs for calm and wisdom and then
there's the side of us that's drawn to
darkness chaos sexuality and madness
Nietzsche was very unfazed by all of
this and it's like he's telling us from
the grave to accept both of these parts
of ourselves and don't try and snuff one
of them out so thanks Friedrich for
helping me understand myself a bit
better and helping me accept the
incredibly complex business of being
human it's well endurance they are
constantly tormented by the elements and
yet because they are an ideal mixture
into our rim naked and all force then
rode him round like a donkey whipping
him and treating him like [ __ ] to show
him who's boss and